iron banner will drop up to three thirty
five trials of Osiris will drop up to
three thirty five ok strike uniques will
drop up to three thirty five exotic
n-grams will decode up to three thirty
five core dvorak's artifact drops which
you mentioned last week will go up to 3
35 and of course the trial are the
challenge of the elders challenge of
elders yep ok cool so let's talk a
little bit about this gun so I just
pulled this out of the vault it is a
reef armament that I would earn in the
prison of elders and this also has
that's right for the first time we get a
customized or weapons alright so I'm
going to customize this gun Keith help
help art direct me here if you could
please I've got a white note on this
that's cool kind of makes the gun pop
just a little bit and go a little
sinister you'll read you could pop a
little blue you've also got yellow ok so
I'm going to check out the yellow simply
because that does kind of complement the
color scheme of the reef then the nice
thing is then the Guardians get a choice
to customize their weapons with their
armor or have their weapons stand out or
have an individual piece of armor stand
out nice so it's a and it's all
integrated in so it looks nice and sweet
but doesn't get in the way nice ok so
you've got a pretty sweet fallen weapon
here yeah this is a this is one of my
favorite scout rifle hmm and what would
you do to trick this out I actually to
be perfectly honest it kind of depends
on my mood ok what a red suit of armor
here you've got the white chroma so if I
go if I go into nice or and give it a
little bit of I'm gonna go for red give
it a little bit of a different look ok
look at mean men so lots of different
ways to customers or weapons with her
suits now nice and let's say that you
were wearing a full suit of taken armor
and you had the twitch you had the
amount show us what you would wield if
you were strolling through this public
space well there's two different ways i
can go I go with the trustee taking
shotgun nice okay or wicket-taking sore
check it out hold the hold very still I
need to enjoy every little bit of this
nasty
look at the effects on that yes so it is
a it's a void sort mm-hmm and it works
with a normal sword mechanics and
gameplay he's just another option for
players check you okay you got one too
nice okay yeah so um I'm uh I'm a
collector of sparrows I'm gonna pull
this out first of all check out my new
ghost oh that's right where do I get
that so that's going to be a prison of
elders drum which which activity in
prison of elders challenge of elders are
the new level 41 match made believe it's
a challenge of the elders ok so this
available coming soon in challenge of
elders what I'm going to do is summon my
vehicle check out this this is this is
badass it's got the new sparrow racing
body glowing and beautiful white and
check you out what do you got this is
the new house of judgments / oh so you
got a sweet barracks ride that's right
and uh and then you're like me yep dude
you shouldn't about the same cars me man
all right follow me I want to see you
put these new swords to good use so
we're going to bound across the dunes
here and we're going to go to my
favorite farming bowl
okay guys where'd you go where'd you go
all right did I save some for you no I
didn't all right we already cleaned up
you should you should clean up that fast
yeah all right you still got some left
i'm sure we'll get some more enemies
here in a second good god you just you
didn't leave i turn my back for one
second and you spent 16 cabal well
you